>> Poverty and disease are major problems
in emerging markets.
Poverty and disease are major problems in
Africa.
They are major problems in India, they are
major problems in the
so-called Third World countries.
Lack of access to education is a major challenge
in these communities.
With better education, better information,
we can go a long way in
addressing poverty and disease in emerging
marketing.
But unfortunately, currently not enough money
is being spent in the
efforts to address poverty and disease in
Africa, to address poverty
and disease in the emerging market.
Why is this the case?
The major problem is that developed countries
feel about AIDS -
HIV/AIDS, poverty, as African problems, as
emerging market problems.
They don't realize that global challenges
are interconnected.
If we don't address poverty in Africa there's
no way we can have
Africans embrace the climate change agenda.
If we don't address HIV/AIDS, HIV/AIDS in
the emerging markets, there's
no way those communities are going to be part
of the agenda to serve
the orphans, the agenda to serve the environment.
In other words, we must understand the need
to address these global
challenges in an interconnected manner.
We must understand interdependence of communities
because if Africa is
not on board on the climate change agenda,
if the poor countries are
not on board on serving the oceans, the oceans
cannot be served.
The climate change agenda cannot be adopted.
So what we need to do is to understand that
HIV/AIDS, poverty, nuclear
weapons, climate change, the oceans -- all
these global challenges are
interconnected.
What we need is a global approach to poverty.
You can not be a rich nation when there's
a poor nation of Haiti next
door.
You cannot be a poor European nation, when
there's starvation in
Darfur, when there's poverty in Zimbabwe.
In other words, the sustainability of the
globe requires all of us,
developed and developing nations, to work
together in attempting to
address the poverty challenge, in addressing
the education challenge,
in addressing the challenge around disease.
Because if we do not do that, the poverty
of Sudan will be the poverty
of America.
The poverty of Liberia, the poverty of Zimbabwe
would define the
poverty of Germany, of Switzerland.
No nation can ever claim two worlds, a claim
to success when the levels
of poverty are dismal within the same globe.
So given this new approach of interdependency
of nations,
interconnectedness of global challenges, we'll
be able to then have a
much more sustainable answer to the issues
of poverty, to the issues of
disease, and people who take a vested interest
approach in wiping out
the disease like malaria, tuberculosis, and
also reducing the incidents
of HIV/AIDS in Africa and elsewhere.
This is what we need to do.
And also we have said education is a key driver
in addressing poverty
and disease.
Hence, the provision of access to education,
the provision of
information, the leveraging of the ICT revolution
is a unique
opportunity by which developing nations can
reach out to poor nations.
So that the poor nations with information
and education can address
their problems around poverty, their problems
around HIV/AIDS, their
problems around economic development.
There's an opportunity here using science
and technology to leapfrog
from the 19th century, where African economies
are, to the 21st
century.
Technology is a big equalizer.
But that technology must be shared.
There must be technology transfer from the
North to the South.
West to the East, so that we
empower and develop ourselves, and in doing
so, by the way, is not
charity.
When Ghana is successful, when Zimbabwe is
successful, when Liberia is
successful, when Sudan is successful, that
will be a key driver for
global success.
So we are saying we must redefine the meaning
of national success.
We must talk about regional success.
We must talk about global success because
we are going to sink or swim
together as a globe.
This is the new way forward around poverty
and disease.